make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to Avengers versus X-Men
versus the eternals where all three of
these groups basically fight each other
at some point over the course of the
story now if you guys want to get caught
up we'll have a little notification
that'll pop up here in a second that'll
take you to the playlist where you can
get caught up on everything but what
this does here is this picks up with the
eternals who have launched their attack
against the X-Men now we covered that in
the last video right we covered the
eternals making their attack against the
mutant nation of krakowa what the
eternals did not account for was the
fact that krakowa has some ridiculously
powerful mutants here some of the most
powerful beings that exist in the
universe exist on this island and one of
them is Exodus which of course we
covered in Exodus quite literally takes
on one of these eternals by himself and
it's kind of a crazy thing because when
that happens he takes this guy out with
a quickness I mean it happens so fast
Exodus just destroys these guys and
that's to be expected because remember
Exodus is one of the most powerful
beings to ever exist in the history of
Marvel Comics the guy's ridiculously op
but the other part of this is that you
do have eternals all of whom have
varying Powers we don't really get the
specifics of this eternal's power the
one that Exodus destroys but there is
one that's attacking the other part of
the island that in fact Cyclops and
those guys are dealing with and that one
has the ability to manipulate the fauna
manipulate basically the plant life and
plant matter around the island so much
so that it actually starts using the
island itself against the X-Men now they
are able to hold their own to a degree
but in the midst of all this the X-Men
are met by the arrival of the Avengers
now I know you guys are probably asking
yourself but if this is Avengers vs
X-Men versus eternals shouldn't The
Avengers be fighting the X-Men we'll
talk about that here in a minute but
when the Avengers arrive on the scene
one of the things to know is that their
arrival here is one part due to the fact
that there's a massive Calamity taking
place but the other part of this is
because of the history between the
Avengers and the X-Men so Lucy guys who
are familiar with this bear with me here
for a second for those of you guys who
don't know what this means in Marvel
Comics there was a story that was called
Avengers vs X-Men and it was amazing
because not only did you get to see the
teams fight each other Marvel actually
released a series of one shots that
focused on The Avengers facing off
against different members of the X-Men
so Captain America versus Gambit
different things like that it was a
really really cool series we might go
back and remaster when they announced
the X-Men and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but the thing about this is
that the Avengers being here is because
of the fact that they didn't initially
want to fight the X-Men in The Avengers
vs X-Men story things just transpired
that way and so because of that there is
a kind of a mixed reaction here Exodus
does not want them here and exodus is a
member of the governing body of the
X-Men so his word goes a pretty long way
but in the end while he is a member of
the governing body of protecting gracoa
it's not really left to Exodus and the
quiet Council to decide it's left to the
war Chiefs and at the end of the day
they're just like the Avengers can join
now one of the things to keep in mind
here is that while this battle is going
on on krakowa that you do have a subset
of the eternals that it actually
abandoned druig who's currently leading
the eternals themselves and he's the won
this Waging War against the X-Men and
presumably The Avengers or at least
we'll see in the future of this story
and so because of that you do have some
of these eternals who are actually
working with Iron Man they're working
with Riri Williams also known as
ironheart they're working with them to
actually Revitalize Avengers mountain
now here's one of the things to
understand Avengers mountain is actually
a giant Celestial and it has been since
that story was introduced since it was
launched by Jason Aaron it's known as
the progenitor Celestial this is
arguably the most powerful of all the
celestials but the significance of the
progenitor is that it was here or at
least arrived on Earth due to an attack
it was already sustaining and because it
was basically dying from the inside out
when it was being killed by The Horde
who were basically kind of like the arch
nemesis of the celestials but what ended
up happening is that when it arrived on
Earth quite literally its blood seated
life on the world and that's how Marvel
offers a modern day explanation of where
life came from on earth that is a result
of the progenitor Celestial but the goal
here of the eternals and Iron Man and
Ruby Williams is to basically Resurrect
The progenitor now the thing about this
and what's really really kind of a funny
kicker here is that you basically switch
back to the Avengers and the X-Men
facing off against each other and one of
the things to know is that the the X-Men
ever since the launch of krakowa have
had the ability to resurrect themselves
it's why it doesn't matter whenever an
X-Man dies depending on the situation
because the quiet council could decide
not to bring them back and there's no
way for that X-Man or that mutant to
return but by and large most all of them
do so even when you had the it was
actually the great uncle of Thanos but
even when you have the great uncle of
Thanos who showed up on on Mars where
you have basically another subset of
mutants residing and killed 15 million
of them at the end of the day they can
just resurrect them all it's gonna take
a while because there's 15 million of
them but they can still resurrect them
at that point it just comes down to
whether or not the mutants want to but
the thing behind this is that uh Captain
America literally tells Cyclops hey
we're definitely here to help man but I
wish you told us before with everything
that we've gone through I wish you told
us before that you had the ability to
basically resurrect yourself and that's
when Cyclops like think about what you
just said man after everything we've
been through you guys waged war on us
why would we tell you that we have the
ability to resurrect ourselves and
that's one of those instances when
Captain America is kind of like okay
yeah you kind of have a point but
basically the X-Men and the Avengers
team up to face off against the eternals
now the cool thing about this is that
again the eternals launching their
attack is happening in multiple stages
they're attacking the mutant nation of
gracoa that's where these gigantic
eternals called the hex that's where
they're focusing most of their attack
but one of the things to remember is
that Neymar the Submariner is a mutant
and as a result of that one of the
eternals one of the members of the hex
has gone to Atlantis now that member of
the hex has basically been dealt with by
a combination of the X-Men and name of
the Submariner who are basically able to
destroy it the problem with this is that
with this destruction basically comes
essentially an explosion underwater and
as you you can imagine is something that
massive right is basically as big as
Galactus or a Celestial if it were to
just explode in the ocean it's gonna
create tidal waves it's gonna create
tsunamis earthquakes all different kinds
of things and what this does is it leads
to what's literally a worldwide Calamity
of essentially these just coastal cities
being overrun and so what ends up going
on is the X-Men tell the Avengers get
out of here go deal with that threat
we'll continue dealing with this here so
where the Avengers leave the initial
kind of offering by Exodus is I told you
guys The Avengers were going to abandon
us and where night crawler chimes in and
says no no no the Avengers are on our
side that's not a fair assessment
Destiny chimes in now remember Destiny
is a mutant that can see the future the
further she looks into the future the
less clear her predictions come and so
because of that because everything going
on here is such a huge event and because
Destiny is able to see pretty accurately
into the near future she corrects
Nightcrawler and says no that is the
case The Avengers really are abandoned
us here this is going to turn into a war
where we are going to be fighting both
the Avengers and the eternals we're
going to be waging a war on two fronts
so it's one of those things to kind of
correct that concern that you guys had
of okay is this really gonna work no no
this is exactly how the event's going to
play out it is really going to be the
Avengers versus the X-Men versus the
eternals now well again while that huge
fight's taking place at krakowa we
basically jump back to Iron Man to Mr
Sinister to the eternals themselves at
least the ones who are not Waging War
against the X-Men and you basically have
them traveling around the world to
different locations and basically
grabbing little pieces of what are
celestials that have existed on Earth at
some previous point in time or visited
in some capacity there was a point in
the past where the thumb of Irish and
the judge had basically been left on
Earth I know it seems kind of weird but
that's effectively taken there was a
point where a piece of the dreaming
Celestial who you guys probably
recognize is tiamu from the eternals
film that dreaming Celestial had been
buried on Earth at one point in time but
there is a kind of Life essence of the
dreaming celeb that still resides here
on Earth at the same time you also have
the Destroyer armor of Asgard which was
created by Odin when they were initially
dealing with the third host the
Potential Threat of the celestials and
Odin and the asgardians and even Zeus
and the Olympians were all going to go
to war with the celestials they
ultimately never did the Destroyer armor
was annihilated and that's when the the
sky followers realized okay we're kind
of out of our league here
we're just gonna leave these guys alone
and let them do their thing but one of
the other big moments to know is that
when it comes to the history of the
celestials on Earth that they had not
just been involved with the creation of
the eternals and the X-Men or at least
mutants as they would come to exist in
Marvel Comics but they also created the
deviance but the deviants were the ones
who initially waged war on the
celestials and so the celestials had
essentially annihilated most all of the
deviants and pushed them to the brink of
Extinction the reason why this matters
is because ever since that point in time
the deviants view the celestials with
reverence they view them as absolute
gods and so the significance of that is
there is no group on Earth that knows
more about the celestials than the
deviants themselves even though the
eternals were created by the celestials
even their knowledge is not that intense
their knowledge is not as in-depth as
the as the deviants are and so the more
significant part of this is actually
Tony Stark himself and this is genius
because in the Christopher Cantwell Iron
Man comics and partially even in the
comics of of the Incredible Hulk by
Donnie case there came a point where
Tony Stark had actually piloted a dead
Celestial now Tony Stark's done that
several times in fact there was one
point where he piloted the god killer
armor which was amazing and if you're
curious about that we do have a video on
that you'll see that card pop up here in
a second you're welcome to check that
out when this video is finished but it
was just a ridiculously amazing story
but because Tony Stark has experience
with basically using the bodies of
celestials and because his body
remembers what it means to be a part of
a Celestial his nervous system is
basically being copied and is going to
be the blueprint and so what this
basically means is that my them going
around and collecting all these
different parts and you've probably
figured this out they're going to use
this to rebuild the progenitor Celestial
they're remaking a Celestial now the
thing that happens here is we switch
back over to the X-Men themselves right
we switch back over to the mutant nation
of cocoa and again you have this massive
fight that takes place now where Exodus
had already destroyed one of the hex
eternals what this does is it leads him
to facing off against another Eternal
known as sign now one of the things to
remember is that Exodus is a telepath
and telekinetic of the highest order
this guy's power is rivaled by a very
precious few people and depending on
what era we're talking about in Marvel
Comics not even Jean Gray who was at one
point a host for the Phoenix force not
even Gene Gray's power is on par with
this guy but the full brunt of Exodus
power comes to Bear when he faces off
against sun and in doing so sign
actually sends out this kind of
telepathic message to Exodus which he
ignores or potentially doesn't even
notice because of the moment where sign
simply says please don't but Exodus
basically detonates himself and in doing
so unleashes all of his telekinetic
energy at one time and Destroy sign the
Eternal now the thing about this and
this is what's so funny here is
initially the X-Men celebrate this as a
moment of reprieve they celebrate it as
okay we destroyed that that Eternal
basically everything is okay ah let's
just kind of keep on keeping on which by
the way I may have referred to some of
the Eternal to celestials my bad the
giant robot things you see those are
basically eternals here the only
Celestial that's part of this is the
celestialis being recreated or being
rebuilt by Tony Stark and all those guys
but the thing behind this is and one of
the things to remember and this was
established during Kieran gillen's run
the dark reality of the eternals which
they didn't know about is that every
single time one of them dies they're
resurrected which they did know about
what they didn't know is a random human
life is taken to basically resurrect
that Eternal there's no Rhyme or Reason
behind why it happens so while the X-Men
do have the ability to resurrect their
own and they prioritize those those who
were either the most powerful or those
who were basically fighting on the front
at the moment the eternals resurrect
themselves as well the difference here
is that when Exodus is resurrected there
is a kind of limit when the X-Men
resurrect themselves their minds are
basically backed up and so when Exodus
was resurrected it's the most recent
backup for his character essentially
meaning it was before this war broke out
so while he is telepathically reminded
of everything that went on for him it's
information when signed the the
Eternal is resurrected she remembers not
only the events and everything that
transpired but how she felt and when she
had begged for her life for Exodus not
to kill her and he did it anyway now it
involves hate and the the war is right
back on again that literally sign
immediately goes back on the attack like
shows right back up again it goes right
back on the attack and when that happens
sign had remembered everything and
learned and that's the difference that
the X-Men are able to learn to a degree
but they're they're you know when
they're resurrected their memories have
to basically be provided to them by way
of secondhand information and that's
what's going on here with the eternals
that the eternals being resurrected
they're resurrected exactly as they were
before like the moment they died they
remember everything including their
emotional state and they remembered
everything they saw all the weaknesses
and all the strengths of the conflict
and that's why sign looks at everything
going on and says okay the only way to
really basically stop these X-Men is to
destroy the island on which they lift
and so sign immediately starts attacking
the island now it's one of these moments
where literally they're just like we
can't stop like we can't stop her like
Signs resurrected here like we just have
people coming back we're still in the
process of resurrecting like Exodus
could potentially destroy sign again but
the reality here is if he tried that
sign would actually stop him because
sign would know that's exactly what he
was going to do sign learn from the past
experiences and so literally all hope is
lost here the mutant nation of krakowa
is about to be obliterated even
Nightcrawler right a man of God is just
like please like please Deliver Us from
this and that right then is when the
celestial comes online and the celestial
immediately sticks his hand out and says
cease and like everybody stops the war
just stops just like that like the the
eternals back off everything just ends
and it's one of those crazy moments
because it's just kind of like okay you
know like you literally have Iron Man
and you've got Ruby Williams and you've
got the eternals who have sided with the
X-Men and the Avengers and who are like
okay cool everything's copacetic we
brought back this Celestial it's under
our control nope wrong this is the most
powerful Celestial ever because it's an
amalgamation of all the other celestials
merged into one and using the bits and
pieces of technology that can be found
it's Frankenstein it's a Frankenstein
Celestial but it's still the most
powerful Celestial and unlike what they
had previously believed to have been the
case which was they could control it the
reality is they can't because it exists
therefore it judges and it literally
says people of Earth listen you are
bickering children the planet is ruined
you have acted with unrelenting
unkindness to one another you leave me
no option this is your judgment day you
have 24 hours to Justify Your Existence
you will be judged individually you will
be judged as a collective if there's
more good than evil among you you will
live but if you are found lacking there
will be no tomorrow I will annihilate
every single one of you with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later peace
foreign